this time around do you get anxiety are
there nerves
yeah ii guess ourselves at all yeah
absolutely i think well sometimes we do
and sometimes we know when we all feel
very comfortable like the first single
don't go breaking my heart yeah we all
knew raff the bat that was the song yeah
I think when we heard the demo and
especially once we knew that we had our
once our vocals once it you know the
final mix was sent to us with our vocals
on it I think we knew off the bat that
was a song for us to come out with but
there's definitely times where we you
know we're not always a hundred percent
across the board
unanimous vote on certain things you
know you know we use a democratic system
and you know hopefully the majority that
that got their way or hopefully made the
right call but you know there's always
second guessing here and there but you
know you just try to go with your gut
instinct and just follow that lead and
and there's also you know there's also
butterflies you know before we get out
on the stage before we present something
you know this is a you know the DN a
body of work is really what makes up the
Backstreet Boys today and our journey so
yeah there's there's still butterflies
they're still the anticipation I think
you channel that energy and want to you
know you want to give your best I mean
you only get that first chance to make
that first impression and again every
you know every album is really a first
impression that's the way we look at it
so when you guys have the inevitable
disagreements because it's five of y'all
who all the talk about in the group okay
here they'd like democratic thing but
like who's the one that you're like oh
yeah I call each other very based on the
scenario it's gonna definitely vary I
think everybody has their moments where
cattle you know but ultimately it is
democratic because you got five of us
and you're not gonna have an even vote
so someone has gonna have to sacrifice
and that's the thing about being in a
group compromise every bump remise and
sacrifice give and take and that's how
we do it it's mostly out of you we all
realize that a passion
but it's not personal yeah at least it's
a passion for something that you want to
win yeah and so it's at least still
going all in the same direction does
anybody get hangry yeah you're going
going going you have any power from now
here jet-lagged if they give you an hour
and a half lunch break which turns into
like 15 minutes yeah yeah you're like a
little bit hangar I feel like you you
really had a moment there you're like I
really get it because you can you can be
you could point people out and but again
it's like there everyone has their
moments of diva's and being angry and
you know all those things so but but
that again that's that's a that's what
it's like being in a group yeah it's a
new album out a song that's already
nominated for a Grammy how cool is that
and also not even just that but where do
you guys keep your accolades are things
like you know pristine condition are
things breaking down are you putting
them in here places I know you guys have
a lot of accolades so where do you guys
put them I've I have an empty spot on my
wall that is for our future Grammy I do
I used to you know I used to become
upset that we were nominated so many
times and we don't have a particular
Grammy I think that's the really the
end-all be-all of total acceptance
that's just my personal opinion really
uh everything I mean come on you guys
are like but I have a beautiful have a
beautiful trophy cabinet yeah at home I
built a beautiful studio to my house in
Georgia I have all of my records up it's
a place that I get to see every day when
I'm home
it inspires me but I have that empty
spot you know that that you thought
freaking mine there's no place like that
Grammy spot we've been we've been
nominated this is our eighth time
and it's definitely an honor to have
that but again you know we've actually
lost in the past and now after 26 years
it's I think the best award ever is
having this longevity having these
relationships with each other you know
so if we don't if it doesn't happen you
know it really doesn't necessarily
matter as much as the reward of of
having each other I know in your no
place music video you guys had kids and
wise and all of that stuff those were
extras yeah yeah I know a lot of people
like to keep you know their personal
life personal or their family kind of
private did you ever have worries with
stuff like that making the music video
or were you just not worried about it I
think with social media and Instagram
and I mean I think to a certain extent
you let let the fans in and let people
see I mean obviously with this video
that's as far as I'm willing to let
people in my life right there but
they've already seen our children
there's just a lot of well wishes
prayers and love coming from our fan
base for our families and we're grateful
to them so we and they're going through
our fans have grown up they have
families of their own they're our
servicemen and women that are away from
their their families all the time and
and and they're a business men that have
to travel all the time and they can
relate to being away from their families
and working and so it's a tribute to to
all of them and I think they can all
relate to and business women to have
business women as well business women
getting out there that's right it's not
easy to be away from the ones that you
love you know but it also it also
inspires you to work hard and know that
you have your place you know your your
purpose you know and that's that's what
we all do is dead are we ever gonna get
a back street kids taxi kids come on
I've encouraged my son to go solo we
thought about the black-eyed peas
version of the Backstreet kids but I you
know Bailey is a little too old
you know to wait on what was it a
two-year-old yeah yeah he's got a little
time he might he's gonna be graduated
college by the time that young kids were
no what are the chances of kids that are
on the same age
yeah if our kids want to follow in
daddy's footsteps then of course we're
gonna support them but if they want to
go and be an artist or a doctor or you
know whatever that that you know that
they want to do we're obviously gonna be
there to show them all the love and
support but yeah they do they are our
number one fans for sure no chances was
co-written by Shawn Mendes he's our
Canadian boy yes yes I bring it up okay
did you guys know that he was a writer
on the song voice was on the demo yeah
yeah I know through the demo our manager
actually manages Ryan Tedder yeah we're
a huge fan of his and we've done some
songs with him in the past one song but
we were talking to to Ron and we were
like hey if you ever get a chance you
know when I asked Brian he finally
finally delivered it but we heard the
demo and we were listening to it Brian
Shaw he was like that is it was actually
potentially for one of his albor his
album coming up but he decided not to
use it and so we went with it we got
blessed with the unfortunate thing and
it didn't go on his album that it
wouldn't work sorry no it's it's you
guys are amazing on it you the Doritos
Superbowl commercial would what is
chance the rapper the sixth member I
just wanted yeah he's trying to be he's
a genius we're glad to be collaborating
with him the theme of the commercial is
taking a classic and putting some fire
on it so you don't want to give too much
away yeah ultimately that spot for a
commercial
yeah homeless states yeah well it's like
the pinnacle of where you want to be for
a commercial biggest Sunday of the year
of the year it's gonna be